for this course will be working pretty
extensively with the idea of a calendar
and to-do list app this ID has certainly
been done before and you probably have
some images in your head of what nap
like this might look like rather than
relying on those though we'll be working
from a set of machs of the sort you
would have developed in the product
design course as you go through this
class remember that each time you do
something with our example app you can
do the same something with your own app
idea which will help you get started on
the final project for the course if you
haven't taken the product design course
or haven't thought enough about your app
to make some very rough mock-ups of the
screens you'll benefit from taking a
detour to that class before you continue
here if you have take some time to
familiarize yourself with the mocks
which we've included below the video in
the classroom page the app design starts
on this home screen here which is then
connected by a menu to all the other
screens of the app currently we have a
frequent action button which connects to
the new event screen as you can see we
only have a basic idea of what should go
where we have a sense that there should
be multiple screens but we don't yet
have a sense of exactly how they relate
or what the arrangement needs to be on
each screen remember you should be
comfortable throwing all this work away
if we spend 10 hours designing the
initial prototype we're going to have to
throw 10 hours of work away we spent 10
minutes on it that's an amount of time
it's easier to get rid of and both will
get your useful feedback at this stage